cubans have taken to the streets of
havana to demand an
end to the communist tyranny that has
ruled the island for 60 years
so it comes as no surprise that our own
communist tyranny here in america
is trying to lie about the cause and the
nature
of those protests but we will get to the
truth
then a prominent conservative
quote-unquote conservative
decries quote-unquote transphobia
hunter biden sells his childish doodles
for half a million dollars and the
public health geniuses promise to make
life
very hard for the unvaccinated i'm
michael knowless the michael knowles
[Music]
show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from
daniel who says why
don't i see schools also handing out
clean needles for
safe drug use or breathalyzers for safe
driving decisions for underage drinkers
that's a great
question daniel i mean this is the kind
of nonsense that we're hearing
from the chicago public school system
when they when they say that they're
gonna
pass out free condoms to ten-year-olds
to discourage
unsafe sexual decisions if you
subsidize a certain behavior in this
case young sex
you are going to get more of that
behavior i know that this
basic common sense is very irritating to
leftists
and to some libertarians by the way but
it's just the case if you subsidize
something you're
very likely to get more of it and we
wouldn't do it
yet we wouldn't do it with underage
drinking and driving we wouldn't do it
with
underage drug use why are we doing that
with underage sex that is a great
question you know people make a lot of
bad decisions
for instance they will go into brick and
mortar auto parts stores
instead of going to rockauto.com when
it's so much easier rockauto.com
is going to save you time it's going to
save you money
it's going to save you dignity all right
because you know you go in look now
there's a million makes and models of
every kind of car so i don't even blame
the brick and mortar guys
they just there's no space to keep in
all those kind of body or auto body
parts so you go in
and they say okay what's your make
what's your model what's your year is it
the zq pc7 whatever the heck you know
and then you say yeah okay it's this and
they go in the back
they don't have the part they go on
rockauto.com they order it they charge
you twice as much you wait two weeks
just don't do it
just don't why would you do that save
yourself that degradation go to
rockauto.com family business they've got
reliably low prices
they don't change the prices every three
hours on some gimmick and you get a
special coupon or whatever you don't do
that
go to rockauto.com it's so simple to
navigate the website
even i can do it same prices for pros
and do-it-yourselfers you head on over
there
you will see all the parts available for
your car or truck and then most
importantly
you write knowles k-w-l-e-s
in their how did you hear about us box
so that they know that we
sent you rockauto.com thank me later
the riots they're not really i guess you
would we're so used to hearing protests
or riots rather be called protests and
and protests be called riots
that it's easy to con conflate the two
but what's going on
in the streets of havana right now is
really much more of a protest
the cuban citizens who are standing up
against their communist
dictatorship are not committing acts of
terrorism they're not burning down
private property like we saw in the
united states
to the applause of the the mainstream
liberal elite in the united states
what we are seeing is cuban citizens
finally after 60 years of communist
oppression
demanding an end to that tyranny and
what's happening in the united states
is that our own ruling elite are
covering up for the communist regime so
there was a twitter trend yesterday
about what's going on in cuba here's
what the twitter twitter trend said
protests take place across cuba
as the country faces shortages of
covid19
vaccines and basic necessities so what
they're saying is
they're redefining the reality of what's
going on and they're saying these
protests they're actually
about how they don't have enough
vaccines for the woof flu that's what
it's not about freedom
it's not about the tyranny that's ruled
the island for 60 years
it's not about the fact that the castros
are finally dead so maybe there's a
chance
to reopen the country a little bit no no
it's about the
chop flooy that's what it's about it's
about the
covid right here's what they described
thousands of cubans took to the streets
in havana
and in other cities to demand vaccines
and food on sunday
as the country faces a period of
economic crisis brought on by the global
kovit 19 pandemic
not brought on by communism brought on
by
the cough that came from china people
criticized president miguel diaz-cane
canel saying down with the dictatorship
according to the miami herald
in a speech addressing the country diaz
can help blame the united states for the
unrest according to reuters
this is an amazing fact
sandwich right so at the top you have a
lie
which is that the protests are about
kovid then at the bottom
you have the lie that's being repeated
from the current cuban dictator saying
that
the united states is responsible for the
protest and then in the in the
sort of in the middle you get a little
bit almost of a fact which is
people saying down with the dictatorship
sandwiched in
between these lies the protests that are
going on right now
are not about kovid they are about
freedom from communist tyranny twitter
doesn't want to admit it but
even jenn saki over at the white house
had to admit
this is about freedom on cuba
you're talking today about how some of
these protests are inspired by people
exhausted with the government
why is it that yesterday the state
department was saying that this was all
happening
out of concern about rising covet cases
well i i would say first that the
protests were just happening yesterday
we're still assessing
uh what is motivating and of course and
driving all of the individuals who came
to the streets but we know
that when i s we say exhaustion the the
um the uh the manner by which the people
of cuba are governed
that can cover a range of issues whether
it's economic suppression media
suppression lack of
access to health and medical supplies
including vaccines
there are a range of reasons and and
voices we're hearing from people on the
ground who are protesting so when these
protesters are yelling
freedom and enough there are people
within the administration who think
they're saying
freedom from rising covert cases
again i would say that when people are
out there in the streets protesting and
complaining about the lack of access
to uh economic uh prosperity
to the medical supplies they need to a
life they deserve to live
that can take on a range of meetings
it's the fact sandwich again she keeps
doing this
so she's she's admitting she's like yeah
right now i know they're chanting
liberty and no it's not
ah yeah it's not well yeah okay it's
liberty
economically and it's liberty
politically and and yeah and it's
liberty from not having vaccines
and it's no it's not it's not it's not
about covid at all no one cares about
kovid jen
it's about communism oh my gosh
if there's any complaint about covet or
healthcare food or anything
it derives from the communist tyranny
she then she can't call out communism
she can't do it she has to say that the
issue is
economic mismanagement there's every
indication
that yesterday's protests were
spontaneous expressions of people who
are exhausted
with the cuban government's economic
mismanagement and
repression and those these are protests
inspired by the harsh reality of
everyday life
it's not economic it's economic
mismanagement in the sense that
tightly managed economies like in
communist dictatorships
don't work out very well yeah i guess
that's economic but they can't call it
out they can't have black and white this
reminds me of obama
when obama went down and tried to
normalize relations
with cuba without getting any
concessions from the castro regime
he said look you know back back in the
cold war there was a big difference
between
capitalism communism but but those i'm
only slightly paraphrasing by the way
those distinctions don't really mean
made so much anymore okay distinction
no they do it does actually the
difference between freedom
and communism is still significant okay
but
because the ruling elite doesn't really
think that because the ruling elite is a
little bit pink they're a little bit red
on the inside
they they can't call out communism this
is not a new
turn of events by the way this has
always been true or it's been true
for the last 100 or 120 years in the
united states
the intelligentsia the the ruling elite
have always been much more sympathetic
to communism
than most of the american people take a
listen to what's going on in the streets
of havana right now
let me know if you think this is about
kovid or mismanagement
[Applause]
by the way so you're hearing libertad
libertad
right which my spanish isn't great but i
don't think that's a that's the word for
kovid
i don't think that's the word for
vaccines i think it's the word for
freedom and you're also seeing
our lady you're seeing you're seeing
statues of
the blessed virgin you're seeing
religious statues this is
i think maybe the clearest example of of
the protests being an attack on
communism communism is about
economic collectivism and about atheism
both of those things at once
in the united states now because secular
liberals have redefined so much of our
political discourse
we only ever focus on the economic
aspect but there's a religious aspect to
this as well
bill buckley talks about this in that
terrific book god and man at yale
it's not just about the economics it's
also about the liberty
this is why during the cold war the
religious right was so opposed
to the soviet union because it was a
ruthless atheist regime
and obviously the libertarians and the
west broadly
were opposed to the economic aspects of
this this is about
freedom and by the way they're waving
the american flag there their way i
remember
i traveled to cuba i visited cuba a
couple years ago when it was easier to
go
and in cuba a symbol of protest against
the regime
is the american flag they wear it on
their jeans they put american flag
stickers on their bicycles
it's the sign of protest here now we
denigrate and desecrate
the american flag in cuba they recognize
that it is a symbol of something
unfortunately our own ruling elite in
the united states
don't seem to have as much care for
america
as the cuban people do and of course of
course
if you really want to know what's
causing the protests and you ask the
mainstream media
you're going to get a simple answer five
letters one syllable
the problem is trump
cbs news covering the
cuban protests right now
makes an argument i thought it was it
was too brazen for them
donald trump is no longer the president
he hasn't been president for some time
now
and yet everything is still trump's
fault including
apparently the sorry state
of the slave island of cuba on cuban
television diaz canel blamed the protest
on the u.s
and its trade embargo for a severe
impact on cuba's recent economic
downturn
the trump administration passed many
more regulations many more sanctions
against it
which basically has cut off all income
coming into cuba
porsha siegelbaum is a cbs news producer
based in cuba
i think the biden administration he at
least said at the beginning he was going
to review this policy
and make changes but nothing has
happened
the recent policy they say the re the
trump administration's
new policy to impose sanctions on cuba
that policy goes back 60 years it's the
cuban embargo
act it has been in place since the
kennedy administration
it is true that barack obama loosened up
the enforcement of that law
but it remained they never repealed the
embargo even when they made it a little
easier to travel there or
you still couldn't buy human goods in
the united states but it was a little
bit easier
all that was was barack obama flouting
the rule of law that's not as though
they actually repealed the law
and then donald trump came in and
enforced the law again and now joe biden
maybe is going to stop enforcing him
quite as much
that's that's the reason that cuba is an
economic turmoil
people in cuba make about 25 a month i
think that's the average monthly income
25
u.s per month that's been true for a
long time
this is true before donald trump but
they're going to blame donald trump for
that this
i i only point this out not to show you
that the media are liberal or something
but just to show you the huge
disconnect between the ordinary people
and the ruling elite not just in
communist countries like cuba obviously
there's a huge disconnect but even in
our own country now in cuba the dictator
miguel diaz-canel who took over after
raul castro
stepped down after fidel castro
died although i suppose fidel castro had
actually given up power to raul before
he died
miguel diaz-canel is calling on the
communist regime supporters to quote
defend the revolution against the
pro-democracy protesters
he said the cuban government is willing
to do anything there are reports coming
out right now that the regime is really
cracking down is murdering protesters
is cutting off internet to the island so
it's getting getting pretty bad down
there
we're calling on all revolutionaries in
the country all the communists to hit
the streets wherever there is an effort
to produce these provocations
we're not going to hand over the
sovereignty or the independence of the
people there are so many revolutionaries
in this country who are willing to give
our lives
we're willing to do anything and we'll
be in the streets fighting
the word revolutionary here is ironic
because the people who are in the
streets demanding an end to this 60-year
tyranny
they are not the revolutionaries
according to the cuban dictator
according to the dictator
it is the the regime that is the
revolutionaries well how how is that
possible
when you go to cuba you'll see an
expression written on the walls written
by the government on the walls which is
viva siempre la revolucion
live always live long live the
revolution
the revolution is a perpetual process
there's no end to it
this is why fidel castro after he had
been ensconced in power as dictator
for decades and decades and decades
would continue to wear his military
fatigues
because the revolution is never over
because
it's one that's the only way that they
can justify the squalor that everyone's
living in and the repression of the
rights
but but two because you can't reach a
communist utopia on earth it's
a utopia it's no place but the paul
kanger the political scientist once told
me that
the way to understand the difference
between socialism and communism is that
christians go to heaven and socialists
go to communism you're not you're not
going to get there on earth
is the problem and so the revolution
always has to be ongoing and we're
seeing this kind of perpetual revolution
here in the united states and i
mentioned the story
in part because i care about cuba i like
the cuban people they're great when they
come to america
they have very good priorities good
family values very conservative sorts of
people
and also because i like the cigars and
the coffee and i like the
cuban culture but really the reason i
mentioned cuba
is not because of cubits because of what
this means in the united states we've
got a perpetual revolution
going on here as well you always you
always hear oh
michael cut it out with the slippery
slope arguments all the left wants
is free sex all the left wants is a
little liberation on the sexual front oh
okay
all the left wants is gay rights okay
all the left wants is to redefine
marriage wait what
all the left wants is from to pretend
that men can become women huh
all the left wants is to start trancing
the kids wait a second come on now
all the left wants is to teach radical
transgenderism in schools wait
hold on wait i thought we were just
talking about
women going to work in the 60s or
whatever i thought we were just talking
hold on how did we get all the way over
here because there's no end to it
because the slippery slope is not just
some fear-mongering tactic on the right
it's the whole point the whole point is
there's no end
the arc of the moral universe is long
but it bends toward justice
we're on the right side of history
history the capital h is always marching
forward we're progressing there's no end
there's no end to it
until you reach utopia which you're
never going to do because it's no place
so we're seeing this now
on racial issues and especially on
sexual issues here in the united states
consider this consider this
right now there is a candidate running
for governor
of california as a republican
who is a man who pretends to be a woman
who is contradicting not just political
orders and standards or social mores
but nature itself and there are
many prominent republicans who are
defending this sort of thing
at cpac at the conservative political
action conference bruce jenner showed up
because he's running for governor of
california
and he was heckled okay and i you know i
don't like this sort of i think it's
ugly to just go heckle public figures
all the time
uh this is par for the course for anyone
who's in political life so it just comes
with the territory and it's just the way
it is
so it's not as though bruce jenner is
special in this regard but still it's
always ugly when it happens so he was
hackled he was referred to by his actual
sex he was called a man rather than his
imagined sex
and he was asked a completely fair
question which is what he thought about
transgenderism being taught in schools
this is a radical
false theory about human nature that
your body has nothing to do with who you
are it is being taught in schools
the guy who's running for governor of
california was asked about this he
obviously
buys into the idea itself because he's
living out that idea and so i think it's
totally fair question
the heckler was rude as happens to every
politician but but the question was was
totally fair
tommy lauren who is a conservative
commentator
i think she's on fox fox news and fox
nation
tommy objected to this tommy wrote on
twitter quote
the attacks on caitlyn jenner are
despicable i'll go to bat for her
every single time and if you want to
take my conservative card for it
take it and shove it your mob is no
better than the lefts and in fact it's
uglier hold on a second now look tommy
lauren is not particularly conservative
tommy lahren famously not only defended
abortion but accused conservatives
pro-life people
who oppose abortion of being hypocrites
because conservatives receive support
limited government
but they also don't think we should kill
a million babies a year
so isn't that hypocrisy it's obviously
not hypocrisy preventing the murder of a
million babies a year i think falls
within the legitimate limits of
government
okay no matter how limited you want your
government to be i
i think that's fair i think that's
within the bounds as
is by the way in this case
standing by the plain basic
fact of reality that men and women are
different
now tommy lauren seems to be saying that
the observation that men and women are
different
is beyond the legitimate limits of
government so what are the are you just
an anarchist then you just
you think the government has no no
legitimate use
whatsoever tommy goes on the
conservatives quote unquote attacking
caitlyn for her personal choices
attacked trump for his and declared him
to be adverse to christian values
they were the bulk of the never trump
pearl clutching movement
that suddenly became real quiet when his
policies worked save your bs
what this that part just doesn't make
any sense at all the people that i look
i know the plural of anecdote is not
data
the people i know who oppose the caitlyn
jenner candidacy on the grounds that men
who
are under the false impression that
they're women
definitely need to figure things out and
probably should not be holding public
office and
probably are not the most conservative
candidates told public office
the ones i know who hold that view
tend to be trump supporters the ones
that i know who are squishy on the issue
of transgenderism
they tend to fall more in the never
trump camp i'm just speaking anecdotally
but i i it's simply a fact that men
men and women are different and i don't
think there's anything bigoted or
hypocritical about pointing that out
also also caitlyn jenner
bruce jenner distanced himself from
trump he backed away from he sort of
liked trump initially and then he
stopped liking trump
and famously he said he doesn't even
care about the republican party
his loyalties do not lie with the
republican party or with donald trump
his loyalty and his concern
is for the lgbt movement my loyalties do
not lie with donald trump my loyalty to
not lie with the republican party
my loyalties and what i'm fighting for
is my community the lgbt community and
particularly the trans issues that are
out there
because there are many of them um and so
that's where my fight is and
i thought trump would be pretty good but
he's kind of disappointed me in the
first 100 days
okay well when he says it believe him
his
his issue is not conservatism his issue
is not the gop his issue is not make
america great again
it's lgbt and specifically transgender
it's pushing transgenderism
oh okay not my candidate then should not
be any of our candidates i mentioned
this not to pick on
bruce jenner and not to pick on tommy
lahren but just to point out
you've got a very prominent conservative
commentator on the prominent
conservative cable network pushing this
stuff
that would have been considered as far
left as it possibly gets even five years
ago
viva siempre la revolucion apparently
you've got a lot of crazy sexual
issues going on why why do these
political issues seem to revolve around
sex so much is it just because people
want to get titillated
is it just because because sex sells or
something
maybe maybe also because sex is
fundamental to our nature i know a lot
of people are talking about racial
politics now the left
uses race also to divide people race is
less fundamental to
human identity than sex is i mean that
that is the fundamental
distinction when you look at the origin
stories of how
humanity comes about they usually don't
revolve around
the racial differences they usually
revolve around sexual differences
gilgamesh or genesis for instance
we'll get into all of that in a second
first however got to tell you about
candace candace's show coming up tonight
tuesday at the 13th 9pm eastern go check
it out the mma fighter
the neil daryush will be on the show uh
cams will be talking about what's going
on in cuba so go check that out
also ben is gonna be talking about
everyone's talking about cuba these days
i'm only talking about cuba to talk
about america but people are really
focusing in on to
what is going on there you could see
another revolution going on in cuba
go check that out we'll be right back
with a lot more
gilgamesh begins with sexual difference
genesis begins with sexual difference
sexual difference is the fundamental
divide in nature so if you can overcome
that sort of thing you can overcome
just about anything in politics and i
think this is why the left is focused on
it
since the second wave feminists who
denied sexual difference into
the same-sex marriage debate which
didn't asexual difference into the
transgender debate which denies sexual
difference
and all of that is in effect an attack
on the family
because the opposite of communism is not
individualism
sometimes it's posited that way that if
we want to fight collectivism we need to
just
support the radical autonomy of the
individual no there are two sides of the
same coin every revolution
first divides people up as individuals
and then bundles them all together this
is true fascism it's true of communism
it's true socialism it's true of the
people today
the actual opposite of collectivism
and radical individualism which are two
sides of the same coin
is the family is community is
tradition that's the opposite
you know we call the left commies all
the time but they behave like radical
individualists when it comes
to sex when it comes to their defense of
privacy
in certain when it comes to abortion
when it comes to so many issues
the left behaves like individualists on
the social front and the right behaves
like individualists on the economic
front
and the country lurches ever further to
the left the country
breaks everybody the revolution breaks
everybody down into individuals then
bundles them back together
the opposite of that would be the family
and that you're seeing a very explicit
attack on the family right now
the rights of the family to educate
their kids the rights of the family
to keep their boys little boys and not
trans them i mean
they're actually now forces at work in
our politics
that will try to take your children away
from you if
you refuse to pretend that your little
boy is a little girl if he says that
he's a little girl you'll get the
schools involved you'll get local
authorities involved
this is happening to a greater extent
outside of the united states but you're
seeing it begin to happen here
as well harry and megan
prince harry and meghan markle the voice
of a generation i'm sorry to say
they just won an award they win lots of
silly awards but they just won an award
from an environmental charity for making
the quote
enlightened decision to limit
the number of kids they're having so
they they've said they have two kids and
that's it they're not gonna have any
more kids they're not going to be open
to life they're not going to be open to
sharing
their love with one another that creates
a new person nope
they're limiting it okay a group called
population matters
is very pleased with this decision quote
in choosing and publicly declaring their
intention
to limit their family to two the duke
and duchess of sussex are helping to
ensure a better future for their
children and providing a role model for
other families
having smaller families reduces our
impact on the earth provides a better
chance for all our children their
children and future generations to
flourish on a healthy planet
we commend the duke and duchess for
taking this enlightened decision for
affirming that smaller family is also a
happy family
wrong it's just wrong so the this
comes out of this fear of overpopulation
we were told by people like paul ehrlich
very prominent
science scientist quote-unquote who
remains at stanford who still gets
lots of plaudits even today he said in
the 70s
overpopulation was going to cause mass
famine mass starvation there was no way
to avoid that
and we had to encourage contraception
and abortion
and if people wouldn't comply with it
then we had to force it upon them
seriously this kind of crazy stuff he
called for
these policies were picked up in india
and china led to
hideous abuses of of people's rights led
to people being denied food or water or
access to sanitation if they continue to
have kids if they wouldn't be sterilized
led to the one child policy which led to
a genocide in china
hideous hideous stuff and it was just bs
because you know what happened
since the time that paul ehrlich said
that
overpopulation was inevitably going to
cause mass starvation
between that time and today the world
population has doubled
malnutrition is at an all-time low
people are fatter than they ever have
been
in the history of the world it's just
not true it is part of this
creepy anti-family anti-life movement
that tells you not to have kids in the
first place that tells you to kill your
kids when you have them
through abortion that tells you to
sterilize your children through
transgenderism
that it's just it all seems to redound
to the same
point wherever you see this this
anti-life thing
recognize there is an economic aspect
here that people just want to have more
money and they don't want to spend it on
their kids
there is a political aspect here it's
easier to control people
if you break down the family and there's
a spiritual aspect too there's just
simply no denying it
there's there is an element of the
demonic in anything that tells you
not to have kids to kill your kids to
have a small family to not raise your
kids right to sterilize your kids
there's something it's not enough to
just talk about the political and the
economic
there's something spiritual there as
well speaking of celebrity families by
the way
hunter biden is back in the news not for
any of the drug stuff not for any of the
sex stuff not for any of the
corruption not for any of the selling
out the united states to china not for
any of the trading on his family's name
quite exactly the reason that's not in
the news is it's not allowed to be in
the news the minute you report
on that that'll be shut down by the
ruling regime here in the united states
it's amazing we talk about how cuba
shuts off the internet for the
dissidents they do it here in the united
states
they do it here when the new york post
uncovers very serious evidence of
corruption and crimes
from the son of a major presidential
candidate what have the regime the
big tech working on behalf of the ruling
elite shuts it down
so you can't even privately message it
to people until after the election
amazing the similarities of la
revolucion here
here and in cuba so hunter biden
is now an artist now i say as a
low-skilled painter myself i took up
painting during covid and i'm not i'm
not very good i'm much better than
hunter button but i'm not very good
i've never been offered half a million
dollars for my artwork
hunter biden has for his little polka
dots that he puts on
on canvas do you think he's being
offered half a million dollars for his
artwork because
it's just so good because it's wow it's
just so beautiful
or do you think it might have something
to do with hunter biden's entire career
which is selling his father's name to
the highest bidder
jen saki at the white house was asked
about this she insists
no big deal no big deal nothing to see
here
did the white house play any role in
crafting the sales agreement with the
new york gallery
to protect the
purchasers or the ultimate purchaser's
identity
well i can tell you that after careful
consideration a system
has been established that allows for
hunter biden to work in his profession
within reasonable safeguards of course
he has
the right to pursue an artistic career
just like any child
of a president has the right to pursue a
career but all interactions regarding
the selling of art and the setting of
prices
will be handled by a professional
gallerist adhering to the highest
industry standards
and any offer out of the normal course
would be rejected out of hand and the
gallerists will not
share information about buyers or
protective buyers including
their identities with hunter biden or
the administration which provides
quite a level of protection and
transparency
anything out of the ordinary anything
out of the ordinary would would be
would be rejected of course and so it's
perfectly within ordinary bounds for
hunter biden for
for a dilettante crackhead sex criminal
influence peddler who took up painting
five minutes ago
to be offered half a million dollars for
his scribbles
that is totally ordinary and normal and
there's nothing to see here
don't worry it's being handled by the
professionals right
right how how do they say this with a
straight face
how because they don't respect us they
don't respect you
they don't respect me they are going to
relieve themselves on our legs
and tell us that it is raining nothing
to see here well it's the same answer
they gave
when hunter biden was peddling his
father's influence
to ukraine hunter biden was being paid
we don't know the exact number something
like fifty thousand dollars a month
maybe more
by a ukrainian energy company hunter
biden didn't know anything about ukraine
he didn't know anything about energy but
his father was the point man on ukraine
and his father
managed to pull some favors it would
seem
while hunter biden was doing that so
hunter biden sells his influence to
china tries to put a big deal together
from china to get some chinese
financing while joe biden is vice
president of the united states
and now hunter biden is a professional
artist adhering to the highest
professional standards
and making half a million bucks and you
know what there's nothing you can do
about it
there's nothing you can do about that
because
you can take to the streets you can
demand libertad liberdad against the
carruccion well doesn't matter
doesn't matter because the ruling elite
will do
whatever they need to do to stay in
power including making your life
very very difficult the former president
of planned parenthood so a
former top abortionist in the country
her
job her career was spent
literally killing babies
to the tune of hundreds of thousands a
year just by planned parenthood alone
she is now on cnn and
she is describing how they are going to
get how the ruling
elite is going to get all you deplorable
irredeemable bitter clinging bible
thumping americans
to take the experimental drug for the
virus that is
so dangerous so terrible that it's got
actually a very very low death rate
and it's so awful and terrible that no
one wants to get the vaccine which is so
wonderful and great
that they're going to make life very
very hard for you
now we have this delta variant that is
much more contagious
because it's more contagious it's going
to be even harder for us to reach herd
immunity
we're going to have to vaccinate an even
higher proportion of people to get there
what happens then if we end up having
another variant developing that's even
more contagious that could cause more
disease that could evade the protection
of our immune system
and so how quickly we get this under
control and which way we go
depends on what we do now when it comes
to vaccination
to overcoming disinformation and what we
really need to do at this point is to
make
vaccination the easy choice it needs to
be hard for people to remain
unvaccinated right now it's kind of the
opposite it's fine i mean it's easy if
you're
unvaccinated you can do everything you
want to do anyway but at some point
these mandates by workplaces fight
schools
i think it will be important to say hey
you can opt out but if you want to opt
out
you have to sign these forms you have to
get twice weekly testing
basically we need to make getting
vaccinated the easy choice that is what
it's going to take for us to actually
end the pandemic
do you see how she gives away the game
here
if the vaccine were so great
well let's back up if the
virus were really so bad if it were
really so dangerous to so many people
it wouldn't matter how experimental or
untested the vaccine where people would
be clamoring to get it if this were the
bubonic plague in medieval europe
people would be clamoring to get any
kind of vaccine they could get
but they're not doing that because
they're not at great risk
then you have to take the question of
the va if the vaccine were so great if
it were so totally 100
safe one you wouldn't be hearing
reports from the cdc by the way i'm not
this is not like from some far off
corner of the internet this is the cdc
in the fda acknowledging
that there are reports of myocarditis
and young young people who are not at
particularly high statistical risk from
covid they're having
issues of heart inflammation heart
hospitalization in some cases death
you wouldn't be hearing reports of the
cova vaccine that or the johnson johnson
vaccine which actually had to be paused
because women were getting blood clots
and in some cases dying from the
vaccine you wouldn't be hearing reports
that just came out yesterday
reported in even the new york times for
goodness sakes of the johnson and
johnson vaccine
causing a uh a nervous system a nerve
issue
you wouldn't be hearing any of those
things which has actually presented
itself in other vaccines even though no
one's allowed to talk about that
you wouldn't you wouldn't be hearing
about that sort of thing and if the
vaccine
were really so great for the virus
that's really so terrible and deadly and
scary
you wouldn't need to make life hard for
everybody because life would already be
hard for people
because the vaccine would already be the
easy choice but because none of that is
true
they have to contrive it they have to
make pretend
this is something you see in
you see greater authoritarianism you see
greater repression
in regimes that are really unstable and
there is no way i think right now
to look at the nature of our politics
and say that things are stable nothing
is stable
nothing is settled the the radicals the
revolutionaries
in the in the middle of the 20th century
unsettled everything
we can't even say what the difference is
between men and women anymore
not even the conservatives can say what
the difference between men and women is
anymore forget about the radical left
even people who are the right wing
people on the right wing networks even
they
are defending this sort of thing so of
course as things are going to be
unsettled
you're going to see greater oppression
greater repression
are ruling elites intentionally making
life hard for people
to get them to succumb to their will
that sort of thing is not happening just
90 miles off the coast of florida that
sort of thing is happening right
in our own backyard
the liberal ruling elite
is coming out and and saying they're
going to go
door to door to try to get you to take
the experimental drug for the virus that
you're not particularly worried about
obviously this is a very strong play by
the left
the right is resisting it except even
some people on the right
or nominally on the right or resisting
it so asa hutchinson
who is not not the most conservative
governor out there
he's a republican republican governor of
arkansas
he made a name for himself because he
supports uh castrating little children
if their abusive parents believe that
the little boys are little girls
he supports that he thinks that that
should be able to go through he opposed
a bill that would ban that sort of thing
so already we don't have very high
expectations for asa hutchinson
well he goes on abc news he goes on one
of these left-wing news sites and he he
says
that biden going door-to-door with the
vaccine that big threat he's making oh
it's not a big deal don't worry about it
whenever we have a low vaccination rate
we want all the help we can
in order to accomplish a mutual goal and
increasing vaccinations
long before president biden said that we
have
community organizations that's helping
us we have churches that are going
uh into homes we have people that go
into
those that are bedridden so that they
can have access to the vaccine
so there's nothing dramatic about what
the president said in itself
no one wants an agent knocking on a door
but we do want those that do not have
access otherwise to make sure they know
about have the information
not everybody goes on the internet not
everybody has that access
and so how do you get information to
them we want to have
our churches involved we want to have
our communities
organizations and if it means going
into a community door by door and
letting them know of this then that's
okay
not everybody has access not everybody's
heard of coronavirus
is that so governor not every the thing
that locked down the entire world for
the last 18 months that has been
blasted on every single news channel
everywhere that if you even question the
official narrative you will be
de-platformed
kick off of social media ostracized from
your community
vaccination centers in every grocery
store
every pharmacy every policy
you're telling me that some people they
just don't know
they just haven't heard about it and
that's why look we don't we don't want
federal agents going door to door so but
we're we're going to send some federal
agents door to door
to get you to take uh or to impel you to
take an experimental drug
and there's no it's no big deal i
mentioned this not because i've had
terrible the policy obviously we all
know that policy is terrible
i mentioned this not even because joe
biden's so terrible we all we all know
that
this is the problem asa hutchinson is
the problem
there is no opposition
what's the opposition party is the gop
the opposition party
because last i checked i'm just looking
at the the headlines today
the alleged opposition party is
defending federal thugs going
door-to-door to jaby with an
experimental drug
the opposition party is defending the
redefinition not even of merit they're
already defending the redefinition of
marriage they're
defending the redefinition of sex itself
they're defending transiting the kids in
some cases they're even defending
critical race theory
and and other kooky theories in schools
where's the opposition
they're not these are the court jester
conservatives these are the people whose
job it is to play the court jester in
the kingdom of liberalism
to do a little dance to give the the
illusion
that there is opposition in this country
but there isn't really they exist
merely to legitimize the dominant
liberal ruling regime
which is constantly downplaying how bad
things really are
there was a poll just came out poll came
out harvard harris poll
came out found out that four out of five
americans
underestimate how bad our illegal
immigration problem is
so it's very simple question how many
people do you think how many foreign
nationals
do you think are pouring across our
southern border every day
harvard harris which is this is not a
right-wing organization harvard
university is not known for its
right-wing politics
harris poll neither
four out of five americans think that
the problem is not nearly as bad
as it is uh 21 americans believe that
less than 10 000 illegal immigrants
cross into the united states each month
more than half of all americans believe
that the number is lower than 50 000
illegal aliens per month in reality
even that 50 000 number is less than a
third of what's really going on
in reality nearly one
million illegal aliens crossed the u.s
border with mexico
in just the first half of this year
forget the legal immigrants who come
into this country our legal immigration
system
is already the broadest most open in the
world
and the majority of americans also
according to a harbor harris survey from
some years ago
want to drastically reduce that
including the legal immigrants
but then you've got a million illegal
aliens coming in just in the first half
of this year
so you're looking at two million
illegals per year
this is a 20-year high in may alone 180
000
foreign nationals poured into this
country
that is almost as many in the first half
of this year has came in during all of
2019.
no big deal nothing to see here nothing
to say here you're not even hearing
those numbers
on most allegedly conservative outlets
why because that's not
that's that's that's not gonna help the
ruling elite
which on the left and nominally on the
right
want illegal immigration to continue 70
of black voters according to a poll come
out right now 70
of black voters say that violent crime
is a major crisis but we're told by the
ruling elite
that no no that's a white supremacist
dog whistle how dare you if you ever
talk about crime you're just you're an
evil racist bigot
can't talk but we'll get into that a
little bit more tomorrow we don't have
time right now
the ruling elite in this country coming
from the white house
does not even want to talk about
election integrity when some republicans
in some states are trying to
put in election integrity laws that
we've had on the books actually in most
cases for a very long time we're being
told that's white supremacy racism
terrible even though black people
support it we're talking about what's
going on in cuba
not only because we care about the
cubans but we care we care about
ourselves and we see what perpetual
revolutions look like
and we see how bad they can get and we
see how bad they can get pretty close to
our own borders and we see how bad
they're getting even here in the united
states
and maybe it's time to push back and
fight for that liber dad and look to
look to the the real roots here not just
even the economic issues the
religious ones people holding up
religious icons but what is it that we
really believe
in where can we find our strength where
can we find our courage because there's
a lot of corruption
that's not just on that slave island
down south i'm michael knowles this
michael knowles shall see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show the biden
administration downplays the evil of the
communist cuban regime
while simultaneously labeling american
conservatives authoritarian races that's
today on the bench hero show give it a
listen